it says today I thought we'd go over
some King and pawn and games and I
decided I'd try to find some scenarios
where there's only a king in two verse
King in two and actually you know it
seems like you know that's the simplest
possible endgame there's just a couple
pawns what could be easier
so I told Darien before the lecture
that's what we're doing he's like well
only the you know should I even come
it's gonna be so easy but actually when
there's less and less pieces on the
board it becomes more and more technical
so it becomes even more important to be
exactly precise and very often there's
only one move I might get the beginning
of the game when there's a you know a
thousand moves you know you can play
anything and it doesn't really change
the assessment an incredible amount but
once you get down you know to the very
very basics you know it becomes a very
technical phase and we'll see how well
we can do it and we'll see some typical
endgame themes tonight so we'll throw it
over to the board now in this first game
comes to us from all rocky of Abdullah
versus Nigel short from 1999 and you'll
notice there's too much stuff on the
board way too complicated so let's
liquidate a lot and in this game white
had played around solidly all throughout
the opening it's been just an equal game
so far he's about two to three hundred
points lower rated than mr. short and
you know how can you possibly lose an
endgame like this we'll see
so he went here and now that we we trade
a little bit more we can see it okay
it's it's two one two looks fairly
standard we'll give you guys one more
move here the king went to be three
opposition which is gonna be a key theme
notice there's an odd number of squares
in between the King I don't have I have
highlighting power and in this position
black decided to play the movie egg for
okay and with this
I think already this is a very critical
position there's you know there's only a
couple moves that you can even possibly
consider here but I would like you guys
especially at home because I'm gonna
pause for a couple minutes to get the
most out of this exercise this one you
really do want to pause constantly
throughout this video so here I'll give
the class a couple minutes to figure it
out there's actually a lot going on and
then mo will give you guys some hints
and we'll talk about it in a little bit
you got a table base on there is that
the set the big trick you should write
you could be the smartest guy in the
class if you're using that thing right
oh looks like my family is here okay
good alright so we've had a couple
minutes
you know maybe way maybe a family will
do a little little pop in okay so does
anybody have any suggestions and in this
position okay so King c3 has been
suggested and this looks you know just
like the most natural move in the
position I mean what could be more
natural than that and that's actually
what was played in the game but it is a
mistake so let's have a look at this
because then we'll understand why so the
King will move over opposition okay and
the fact that it is black that maintains
the opposition white has to keep moving
you know and then black and keep the
opposition until eventually he can run
to either side and win one of the ponds
so in the game he went over to d3 yeah
of course
in here I guess he realized that he was
in a little bit of trouble in the game
will just show it because it didn't last
very long
he played king d2 cuz I guess he
realized going left loses going right
loses he played King d2 nigel played
King before or opposition and okay the
game ended here so I guess white you
know either didn't consider what was
going to happen in this position or he
thought this was equal but I would like
to challenge the class here just a
little bit
okay which way would which way would you
guys go we're gonna look at both it
doesn't really matter
left right just keep going right okay so
now black has the opportunity to go run
and get this guy so he's going to go
that way and these are this is sort of
the theme that's gonna be important and
I know a lot of people struggle in
simple things like this where you have
to calculate upon race so I do want to
know I'll ask you guys one sort of
tricky question to see how well you can
calculate this where will White's pawn
be when black Queens that all show that
you know you know what's going on let's
see if you guys can calculate the whole
the whole way black Queens by taking
this okay interesting question so you're
thinking
let's white to move right so where did
did useful go up okay
insulin here you're gonna do this and
then I go here
so if this happens then yeah black wins
because I do get to get out and I can
even run and go get this guy if I have
to you know I can I could start going
immediately which will win for black
okay so okay we'll put this on the board
so yeah there's you know an important
idea sometimes there are you know you
can still make the King sort of on the
side but here it just doesn't work so it
is a race Black's gonna do this one two
three plus three is six one two three
plus five its - yeah so okay so the
question is though just to make sure we
actually can see all the way to the end
because these things are sort of
important where will the White Pond be
when black means now kind of show that
you've actually calculated the whole
thing do you know G six okay excellent
so yeah if we just do this race you know
we push the pawns on g6 excellent and so
you know often for some reason it's only
kids that ask me this but they're always
like how many moves do you see ahead and
well it depends you know in a race like
this seeing 10 moves ahead is a lot
easier then position where there's only
moves and it's sharp and crazy so and so
it is important to be able to do these
cuz I know a lot of people they just
like they're too afraid to even
calculate races and stuff for some
reason but I mean you have to be able to
do that to play in games like this and
it's very similar if we go this way I'll
go get the other guy and just to
practice where will the pawn be from
black Queens over the white pawn be
yeah
a six okay I go get you you go get me
here I go then the pawns on a six one
black Queens okay let's go calculation
you left but it's not it's not that easy
for you know a lot of people so already
we can see in this position sort of the
problems that we're gonna be facing so
the fact that black has opposition
actually is a very serious problem
because he can just keep the opposition
all the way you know until we're forced
to go one way or the other and then he
just goes the other way wins the pond
and because his pawns are a lot closer
to queening he'll win most of the races
so and in this variation all the races
so we return here you may want to pause
again that was not the solution so no
but it's the most natural move so that's
what I mean that's why I you know 2,400
played it in the game and I think that's
what almost anybody would just play
that's just the most natural movie can
play but it's not correct King c2 okay
and so yeah the problem of course is I
get an opposition there's only one
square between us so did you did you
want to keep going you're gonna start
going which way you like you can't even
really go this way this is this is an
easy race you're gonna zigzag just pick
moves because there's only a couple of
them oh I got I got four King moves and
I'm in check okay yeah so we know we
don't half of them
King 82 so okay the classes is undecided
is it a 2 or B 2 okay and that's yeah
that's exactly what would happen okay so
the class is voting for a 2 so that was
the fourth option that's that's not
right so what we'll get down to it I
mean I see Michael here the right move
was mentioned yeah black me a Mexican
just yeah this is just an easy race and
also if you just looked at these and you
were able to calculate that those three
don't work you would come to the right
answer which is king b2
and of course we're a little bit worried
because there's an even number and it's
their turn so they can get the
opposition and so what Darien did
mention is you know probably the most
critical attempt black going here but
just to make sure we're all on the same
page we'll go over some other options
that black might choose so let's say we
go to c4 hopefully this the next move is
pretty easy king c2 and again we just
maintain the opposition and so this when
white has the opposition it's really
easy to draw this but here I'll test you
you know obviously I didn't have to play
there I had maybe some other moves I
could you know run around here but I'll
just test you so again we have another
little pawn race it's important to be
able to calculate these so so what
happens here
Blackman's yeah that's yeah this assumed
white is gonna go do this and like it's
gonna go do this who's gonna win this
race
and it is one of those things where you
have to just calculate you know in a
bliss game you might have to kind of
into it looks like I'm first but you
know if you're wrong you you throw the
game away and to throw it away at this
point it's move 70 and you've you know
you've played really well against a
strong Grandmaster you know you you
don't want to throw it away with just
some sloppy calculation right at the
last second here okay and you said black
wins the audience they've all decided
black wins and white pawns on g6 okay so
King f3 is a big mistake and it looks
like somebody's calculated it right what
yeah the pawns on g6 well black Queens
so I mean okay so King to c4 in this
position is not a very critical line
because white easily gets the opposition
what about not this one you look at that
one
but you know you feels good when you get
it right for a second time okay this is
a little more challenging I go back can
you see - yeah exactly
you need to maintain distant
opposition's so we got three squares
it's an odd number so again it's gonna
work out for us so the big mistake that
you know perhaps a lot of people at home
would make I guess the audience was on
fire is here and then black gets the
opposition and we've seen this position
where white is forced to move and black
goes the other way so we've seen this
critical position so we know we don't
want to arrive at that
so after here here the right move is
king c2 and when they move over
obviously you want to keep distant
opposition so King d3 would be a big
mistake as long as you keep an odd
number of squares in between you're
doing fine
and this should just end in a draw so
going back here for the last time will
play probably the most critical way that
black can play so black has the
opposition
this whites turn so white is forced to
move and there's an easy way to draw
this and a hard way
so we'll see do you guys think you guys
want to draw the easy way or the hard
way and it's it's about to get a little
bit harder one of these variations I
think yeah probably whatever is the easy
one that will be the artist does nothing
mean yeah yeah it's so easy it's just
two ponds but these are usually some of
the hardest positions can you see - okay
so you want to do it the hard way okay I
go here resins it's a draw
you want to resign it's a draw but you
know good luck I'm not offering a drop
goes good luck
King d2 okay and okay here's the
critical juncture white has to decide
here
so here again for maximal benefit you do
want to pause I'm gonna give the
audience a lot of time here like five
minutes or something this is a very very
tough decision so I will give you guys
time at home I'll probably just go see
what my son's doing over there he's
getting his first standing Machuca
lesson so uh yeah I probably got to see
what that's all about what was your idea
King you two okay we'll have a look at
it okay me too
is that the right move all right I go
here and we reach the same position that
we've we've seen some weight decides
which way to go and black goes the other
way okay
and you really I mean there's three four
or five moves that you have to consider
here and simply you just have to
calculate them all until you you find
the right move
you know what what do you see that guy
or the lights yeah I know it's bright
it's bright up here people at home don't
know how hard it is this the pen yeah
there you go
that alright yep no I don't want to eat
it oh it's not my favorite flavor king
b1 all right not even on the radar okay
I mean like and then resigns okay those
that was good calculation okay King c2
let's see do you think he's right no
it's not right I go here
and if you go here here and if you go
here we'll see you and you didn't
calculate the race okay mm-hmm yeah
who's gonna win the race here I know
it's so hard for them all right
let's help them out a little bit you
like blacks chances all right you don't
wanna get tricked or I could check in
and take it but but however I want to
win
let's see okay here we go because yeah
everywhere you go you have to calculate
there's races on the board so there's
nothing to do but brute calculation yeah
if they both queen you know perhaps then
you're looking at a draw you have to be
careful but there's some tricks okay
so they'll both queen but it'll be
blacks turn King III yeah you calculated
it perfectly and what's what's your
rating now 6:30 yeah and it's just it's
going up and this I mean yeah we got
some some decent players in here a 2200
player 18 1900 player mm-hmm and yeah
the the highest rated players given like
nonsense lines and and the little guy
there he actually he's actually putting
in the work okay so here's the line for
those and look at this yeah so perfect
so you saw this position I mean you must
have right yeah that's exactly what you
said but aha
can you see that and you know you have
to be careful there's I mean there's an
only move here you have to stay close to
your queen because other yeah really
otherwise yeah Jack and okay you can
keep checking or trickling so ever you
want to draw so that was perfect I was
wonderful
alright hopefully hopefully some of you
guys got it at home you can hopefully
you guys can play like like Jason woolum
superstar huh he's on to big things so
let's let's go here one one last
finishing move here their sole do it for
this puzzle yeah this is a little little
easier if black just please this way you
can go here what's gonna happen now also
we could have gone to f5 for
so f5 I mean this is pretty simple draw
so the only last question here is king D
for what happens so again it's just a
good exercise just to try to calculate
the race see if you can see what's
what's gonna happen when both sides
Queen or who's gonna win what's going on
it's the same exact thing yeah so yeah
everybody Queens and of course you just
have to be careful here and it's a draw
so wonderful yeah we were able to solve
that one so we got the easy puzzle right
so that's good will draw the easy way so
after King b2 black the most critical
line is to play here now the easy way to
draw is King b1 it is because you know
if you ever come up then we get the
opposition now you can keep the super
ultra mega opposition but again it's
it's pretty easy to draw one there that
far away you just wait for black to walk
into a position where you can get them
and if sorry after King b1 he tries to
say here there's one more little detail
here what should we what should we play
here is white king c1 exactly just in
opposition and not not king c2 because
obviously again we walk in to a
situation like this and okay black go
white goes one way black goes the other
and wins
so okay as long as you remember to keep
an odd number of spaces it'll be a draw
all right so we're probably not gonna
get two we got a viewer submission that
I kind of wanted to do but I think we'd
rather let's just do with you the hard
one so you got the easy one right oh and
you know 40-something minutes this is
the game between Vladimir Kramnik and
vladislav to check give and I pronounce
some of that part some of it right
never pronounce anything right and good
thing we're not doing the viewer game
because I got no chance to pronounce on
that guy's name this was from the Moscow
tall memorial blitz from 2008 so it was
a blitz game and some mistakes were made
because we're gonna get to a position
that's you know very difficult to
evaluate and okay it was a blitz game so
both sides made mistakes we'll get we'll
get right to it so white it's been in
sort of a commanding lead you know from
the early middle game and he's finally
getting ready to convert so there's some
trades here we go it's King and two
first King in two and I mean perhaps at
first sight it might look obvious I know
I showed Dany Machuca easily all this is
easy I just go I just go like this and I
munch all these guys you waste your time
you go get this guy meanwhile I go here
and I just make sure that I a box your
king out however I have to do it so you
don't get to the corner okay easy well
it's not that easy
so four time we'll just we'll go over
the the obvious moves white is gonna go
try to go get all the black spawns black
has to come back and here so this is the
challenge it's white to move and this I
think will stump everybody because
there's a lot you have to understand
about this position so make sure you're
thinking you know you might think what
do I want to do is white but also what
is black gonna do in response to any
move that you might make okay so your
idea is to put this here and then you
somehow force some sort of subs long
where you get to like this guy's here
and this guy's here something like this
and you take this and then you go here
and like everybody Queens but you queen
with checkmate something cool like that
which will be a theme sometimes in like
lines where they play a five that's but
he doesn't have to King e6
yeah I assume I'll push this one now go
run where'd you want to go d6 yeah
we go here and so this is the race we
have to calculate ken white go and pick
up that pond before I can grab this and
run to the corner in that suspicious
fashion we don't have time to draw
straight arrows so if here I mean you
can go here right and so I guess the
question is can I just go here take this
and get to the corner and I mean it
looks like I can right
I mean what you want to play here you
want to go try to give me you know I'm
just I'm gonna make it
I can even probably go run down and get
your pond or so this should actually
lead to a draw and so for the sake of
time hopefully you guys have as much
time at home and I really really hope
you've put an effort into this one
because it's it's really nice in the
game the move that was played was king
c7 which just looks like the most
natural move you could ever play you
know it's a blitz game very strong clear
I mean it's just I think that's a move
that everybody would play but it's
actually a mistake that blenders have a
point
so black now can draw but failed to do
so cuz you know how do you draw this as
black that's the next question so we'll
look at the game in the game
a5 was played which is wrong it should
be what King g7 okay we can have a look
at that well look at King g7 let's go
ahead and just go right through the game
here if you take this is actually a
mistake we'll come back which is not
what was played in the game a4 which is
correct if the King takes you get to
push a little bit farther and you want
the King to have to run as far away from
the corner as possible before he takes
your pawn so you want it to be really
really far away and it becomes a big
race that you know has to be calculated
correctly but okay the King just goes
back and he makes it which is why sorry
in this position
a4 is what he played in the game and now
the race is on hopefully we can
calculate it from here
he's black gonna make it to the corner
in time you don't think so you think so
all right let's see who who calculated
better you didn't make it in white
Queens so that was the the game in y1 so
going back to this position it was no
sorrier than this was in this position
here it was suggested king e7 okay takes
King e6
okay well look at King e6 and are you
gonna make it to the corner
now be careful what should white play
here
yeah you want to get into this position
where your next four moves are just
pushing and cleaning no a funny mistake
is here because it looks sort of like we
have that other example where you know
it was sort of the similar you're trying
to steal man I'm on the side of the
board but here it actually works and
yeah the black King gets to the corner
so I so I mean okay I'm going back to
this position one more time
King e7 you know right but the the move
to to really save the the draw here is
this move b5 so we're beginning to
understand what Black's idea is in this
the initial position he wants to play
the move b5 make it hard for you to go
get his pawns now you can either play
King b7 and you can go try to round up
the pond or you can play a three if you
play a three you get embarrassed by what
move a5 black makes a passer King b7
however you can do what what will you
guys play in this position
before and this is this is one way to
make a drop so and again for time we're
gonna speed through it but you know
pause at home make sure you calculate
this race because it's just important
practice is black gonna make it into the
corner in time okay well what to speed
through it unfortunately and you
calculated it okay good
not only like the lower rated players
calculate in this class for some reasons
some people are too high rated to
calculate I guess okay so one more time
b5 King b7 okay one one mistake would be
here because I can go here and I'm gonna
get one of your pawns and then I'll win
also after this move there's another
move that that equally draws you can
play here and even let him go get you
because you still make it to the corner
so there's a couple ways to draw so
let's return now to our original
position and so we know blacks idea now
at least we know a little bit so you
play King c7 he plays b5 okay so this is
the idea so again whites turn to move a
for the blunder I was hoping people with
me I was trying to mislead you slightly
so you'd say this because it's important
to analyze this this is you know
probably the most natural move okay I
see okay you don't play b5 I play a four
and the next I play King c7 but black
goes here and what were you guys going
to do here is as white so the King can
no longer make any progress you can push
one of your pawns or which one would you
like
ecigs okay sure I'll play here and as
you know as a general rule you don't
want this pawn getting closer to the
coining square because in races that's
means I'm gonna be quicker to capture it
and this
actually should be a draw so for example
you can go get my stuff
and I make it to the corner
and even if you go here I just wait
until you have to get out of the way so
ok I mean just as a general rule you
don't really want to be pushing that guy
so a 5 makes a little bit more sense
even though the simple move here there's
a simple move and there's a hard way so
that's something to ask you because you
like the hard way what can black play in
this position you picked the easy way
yeah you played b5 white take some
pissant and then you know he goes to get
your pawn you go get his pawn house
counting on you say b6 yeah yeah say b6
so hey b6 and it's yeah this isn't
really necessary to the puzzle but I
just think there's some interesting
ideas in this position mostly occurring
after a 6 we'll just look at one line
here a 6 this is the interesting line ok
black to move b5 and that n King e8 also
is a draw and they're very similar but
can we calculate this traces
it's not gonna make it to the corner in
really a home you should be you should
be positing and trying to see if you can
do it because that's sort of the whole
point of this lecture pretty sure
alright the highest-rated guy's pretty
sure look at the the lower rated section
yeah right yeah you too I ready to
calculate it why don't you want to
calculate you want to push the beep on
why not
all right and so here it's not gonna
make it
oops
and what computer wants to go there
that's a bad sign
alright that looks pretty good also
drawing is King e7 yeah
yes you cannot calculate and then maybe
you're right
maybe you don't blunder the game away
80% chance I mean okay and yeah you do
really 100 percent chance of being right
don't you hey because these are these
are very critical positions in a real
game but yeah I mean to get better you
mean you study eight positions like this
so so another thing so a4 which is sort
of the right idea if we look at this
position because this is a critical
position I have one other question and
this is sort of a question you can
usually ask in end games especially when
there's opposition what if it were
blacks turn to move in this position
then what would the evaluation be if I
go here what happens
it doesn't look good for black why
what's like gonna do yeah he's gonna go
grab all these ponds so this is just a
much faster way of doing it what if I go
here though the simplest is I mean it's
going here then you get three pawn moves
to clean them so I mean the King moves
don't work a five okay well show this
let's see
I uh I could I could make it blacks turn
but then computer would be minute but
but Darien would be happy because it's
it's his his variation finally realized
I could triangulate both yeah who would
triangulate in a game class just to make
it blacks turn because you have here you
can't go on with this idea and then yeah
the point is your next move is like here
and you know this sort of happens and
eventually black will be forced to do
this and your idea does work in a lot of
lines 885 just doesn't work and if you
play b6 you know you're weakening the
queenside and that does also let me just
run in so if it were blacks turned why
it was winning there's just no good move
so we return and so we know the basic
ideas now we know if we just play king
c7 do they play b5 and that's not a win
and we know if we could just you know
sort of waste a turn and black had to go
here and we had you know we could play a
four and then we'd win so with that
being said hopefully we can find the the
very brilliant move that could have been
played in this game a3 yeah so this is
the move and obviously in a blitz game
understanding a3 is the hardest thing in
the world
it just Kramnik but you know I assume
the game is probably like five two or
something like that it's you know you
just in it so in blitz you do have to
play more like you intuition
you know yeah maybe I'm right you know
cuz I don't have time to actually figure
out a three because maybe it'll put in a
longer game you do want to be thinking
I'm gonna go here what's my opponent
gonna do work out the races because this
is really where you know half points are
won and lost which can mean so much for
tournament standings and for your rating
and just your general chest strength you
know being able to find really powerful
moves like this over the board is tough
and it just takes time you know working
through puzzles like this so a three is
it's just the move and okay if I go here
we can look at a couple other moves a
four and white wins it doesn't matter
what you do so let's let's suppose okay
b5 this was our idea before right let's
just give me five ago what will white do
now
King c5 why not c6 just control this
square why not okay and now what should
I play here I need to make sure black
doesn't make it to the corner
King b7 so again you have to be very
accurate and of course the main theme of
the day opposition is the key and if
they try to get to the corner is the
last chance opposition and you just shut
them out and now you have a lot more
pawn moves to make and then you you'll
win the game
will be v just doesn't work in this
position don't anything else that will
calculate today at least is a 5 so you
get one more chance here to play with
white
a for good move and the only move again
you need to make sure that you know you
don't want their pawns to go so far away
that's an extra tempo you're gonna have
to waste with your king so a for
absolutely okay I go here yeah
you push Steve on okay I go here
push it again I was Darien finally gonna
get his his big wish
okay I go here yeah okay you know what's
gonna happen
resigns you can cat for four you're not
scared to black rook obviously obviously
the right choice so hopefully I mean we
don't have time to go over the game top
temps should be here any minute we'll
get the next class going so hopefully
that helped you guys improve your
endgame skills calculating all sorts of
stuff tell me what you what you thought
about it yeah you know hit like share
subscribe tell all your friends tell
your neighbors call your grandma up and
tell her all about this show and I will
see you guys next week thanks for coming
out